good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is run after your
destiny over to you Bishop TD jakes
[Music]
life demands that you pick up the pace
if you don't pick up the pace
you're gonna be left behind I'm amazed
at the people that lack the flexibility
to pick up the pace they just get in a
red I scroll down here and I'm gonna
scroll back I'm gonna stroll over here
I'm gonna stroll over there one of the
most amazing thing about the disaster
and Malaysia is that when it happened
everybody had to pick up the pace all
the news media had to pick up the pace
they were booking night flights and
flying over here and flying over there
somebody had to work overtime won't be
home for three days typing in the middle
of night research going or because when
something happens everybody gotta pick
up the pace that's why I can't deal with
people who cannot pick up the pace
don't be strolling when I got a 9-1-1 on
you i need people who can pick up the
pace slap the neighbors say pick up the
bass
something's about to happen pick up the
pace something's about to happen pick up
the pace something is about to happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen pick up the pace something is
about to happen
pick up the pace something's about to
have it I came to tell the young people
pick up the pace pick up the pace pick
up the break something about the danger
of low expectations
I would rather aim for the stars and not
hit them then to not aim at all I would
rather go after it and not get it did
not go after it at all I'd rather try
and fail did not try at all I don't want
to live with the idea wonder what would
have happened had I done more with my
life
I'm gonna go for it come hell or high
water I'm going after my destiny touch
the neighbors say run you gotta run
after your destiny you can't stroll
after your destiny
you can't walk after your destiny you
gotta run
somebody ha
you gotta run you gotta run you gotta
run
you can't just wake up in the morning
let me see what's gonna happen today I
don't know I don't know where I'm gonna
go I just woke up oh you should stay in
the bed give the day to somebody who's
gone wrong after their destiny give the
day to somebody who has a plan who has a
strategy because success is never an
accident and if you don't want it get
out of my way because there are some
people who want to do something with
their life if you know what you want to
do if you have a clear vision in your
head for the something you want to
launch a person you want to pursue some
opportunity that you want to go after
like if you know you have a crystal
clear picture of what you want to do
then you need to go after it right now
most people sit on it most people have
genius ideas and they sit on it for
their entire life and then they see
somebody else make tons of money off of
your idea right and you get you get old
and grumpy and you start to complain and
that's not a life that you want that's
not a life that I want for you either
it's not that somebody stole your idea
you didn't put in the work you didn't do
anything with it it was their idea and
they deserve all the success you can't
look at them and be bitter and angry
that they stole your thing when you did
nothing about it this is important
whenever you have an idea whenever you
have an opportunity and if you you want
to go off and pursue something there's a
window of opportunity for that thing to
happen there's a window based off of
your life circumstances based off what
the market wants based off you know
where you are right now your mindset
your interest your passions your skills
desires there's this window for this
thing to happen and that window maybe
six months and maybe a year maybe two
years but it's like there's a limited
amount of time and that window is going
to close and that's why you need to run
that's why Bishop Jake's is so
passionate about running towards it
because that thing is not going to be
there forever and if you wait too long
or you're a crawl and you're walking
you're barely getting there that windows
gonna shut in your face you're gonna
miss your opportunity where you could
something amazing if you just ran at it
and I think what you'll find is it's
definitely in my life you'll have
moments of certainty and uncertainty
uncertainty uncertainty and you
constantly kind of ride these right
these different waves it's important
when you get that moment of certainty
that clarity that you go all out and
when you don't know what to do when you
have the moments of uncertainty then
you're exploring you're trying to find
something you'll want to get stuck on
one path that's not right for you and so
if I look at my career as an example
when I was with my software company
right 19 years old had my biotech
software company I knew what I wanted to
do I was grinding I was hustling every
single day putting the work in crazy
number of hours and that was three years
of my life and then when I sold the
business I didn't know what to do you
know I didn't know what I wanted to do
and I explored and that was the
uncertainty so the software company
certainty working hard every day running
trying to get my dream that happened and
we sold our business at the right time
right we sold our business before the
window closed if we didn't push as hard
and we didn't run as fast and we waited
we would have missed our moment and I
wouldn't have been able to sell my
company so I sold it then I didn't know
what to do next
wandered explored traveled said yes the
whole bunch of different things and
that's where it's hard to see measurable
progress when you're uncertain you're
trying many different things and most of
them are going to work out a lot of the
things that I said yes to was a one-off
thing and I knew I'm not gonna go back
and do that again until I found my next
level of clarity my next moment right
the next wave riding up which was with
the website I had my website I was
creating content it was doing well
people asked if they can be cheaply
content to my website that started doing
well then I realized you could make
money from the website with advertising
and so I realized okay this is this
could be the next big thing but I can't
create all the content myself I need
other people I need an army and so we
recruited five thousand plus people to
write for the website and we got big
earnings we got Seth Godin and Guy
Kawasaki and Donald Trump who at the
time was doing Apprentice and you know
was the big name in entrepreneurship
but Zig Ziglar and Jack came feel like
big big name people to contribute
articles to the website and I just was
singularly focused like here's my window
right the window was there for now I got
a run at it I got to throw everything I
can at it I got to get as many people
get as many articles run and in the
combination of me losing my interest for
doing that side of the business in the
market changing and Google's algorithm
changing led to that window shrinking
that that was not as big an opportunity
anymore and so I got everything I could
out of it well that was lasting and then
I go back into this uncertainty like I
mean what should I be doing I need to do
something else with my time I need to
focus and I need to build something else
I'm I don't know what I want to do I'm
exploring different paths one of those
paths happened to be YouTube I made a
couple YouTube videos this was pretty
cool I like it I like the feedback I
like how it feels to be on camera I want
to do more I want to share my mission I
want to have an impact YouTube seems to
be an interesting way to do it and then
as I started doing more of it I realized
this is a moment this is my next window
I got a I got a go all out
for you guys who have YouTube channels
and are complaining about trying to make
one video a week two videos a week I
realize that this is a window right now
that I figured it out right now how
things work how YouTube works how the
other grism works how reaching
entrepreneurs work how to make good
videos like it's all coming together in
a perfect storm for me right now
and I need to run it's why I make it
three videos a day it's why I'm grinding
so hard you creating content it's why
I'm building up my team to real answer
your comments and take requests and make
new series it just is all working right
now and you'll have those moments right
I've recognized it it happened with my
website it happened with my first
business this is where I'm at right now
this is my moment on YouTube to run hard
as fast as I can and I'm sure at some
point I might lose my interest in
YouTube the algorithm might change with
the way that I'm doing it may not work
anymore and that window will close and
then will lead back to that uncertainty
testing things out and it's just
constantly doing this that's you know
your entire life
and so when that wave comes when you
find that clarity when you find that
focus when you know what you want to do
it's so important that you run after it
because you will have these few moments
in your life where things just become
that bit so clear that you have to go
and do it and unless you do that window
will shrink will shrink will shrink will
close somebody else will make huge money
huge impact off of your idea and you
have to wait for the next thing to come
and maybe there's ways to speed that up
but when you get that moment of clarity
I'm urging you to run as fast as you can
as hard as you can for as long as you
can so the question today today is I'm
curious what were those moments of
clarity in your life that weighed that
you needed to ride what are some of
those that have come up those three of
the four moments maybe one or two maybe
you haven't found it yet but I'm curious
what are those moments of clarity that
you had that this is the wave everything
is matching up for me my interest my
passion my skills combined with the
market and where it's going that it just
made sense that now I need to go all out
that now I need to run I love for you
the sheer experience leaving the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Girish thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me and I hope you enjoyed
the read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go
while baseball when I was four or five
six years old it was my first love the
first thing I fell in love with and I
thought most of my life I thought that I
was gonna pursue baseball as a
profession second hardest decision in my
life then we're sitting on the edge of
my bed crying over it deciding what I
was gonna do and I ended up choosing
football and I don't regret that but I
do believe in pursuing passions and
what's on your heart and this is
something that I'm passionate about
we'll just say about you that you're
even given the opportunity as a 29 year
old man who hadn't played baseball in a
decade there are certain things in life
that we love and we have chances to
pursue them but a lot of time the fear
of the unknown the fear of failure gets
in the way I don't want that fear to
creep in I don't want the unknown to
creep in I want to be someone that I
pursue whatever is on my heart with
everything I have and if I fall flat on
my face and guess what I'm gonna get
right back up I've read that you're a
farce I've read that you're a joke I've
read that you're an embarrassment not
only to yourself but to the game of
baseball the first thing is I'm so
thankful that I don't have to read it I
don't have to listen to it I don't have
to live the roller coaster that the rest
of the world lives of my life I don't
care what they write about me they've
written a lot of things over the last 15
years about me some good some not good
some just because they want to sell
papers
I don't necessarily care at the end of
the day I want to pursue my passion
because I believe when you're pursuing
what's on your heart when you're
pursuing what you're convicted by then I
don't have to live with regret 10 15 20
years from now looking back saying what
if what if I would have tried that worth
the success is if I give my all to it if
I get to live out that dream every
single day whether that's in single a
double a triple a worth in the big
leagues you know because joy doesn't
come from success joy comes from knowing
your design and being able to pursue
that every single day and knowing that
I get to live out a dream so all that
stuff I was just dreaming about like
this is the possibilities that can
happen if I moved to California or you
know because I was working really hard
here and a lot of comedians come down
from LA and say man you need to go to
California cause she's pretty good I was
getting a lot of good advice and a lot
of people who was really rooting for me
yeah just went and did it but I had a
dream and that dream gave me no
confidence to keep going the power of
believing and dreaming is real because
that's all I did was dream and believe
and that these things could happen and
it made me feel good and that was my
that's true wealth if you believe and
you're doing something you have a goal
you have a dream to get somewhere it
makes you feel good honestly that
there's no difference the way you win it
the way I win at the game I'm a go at
business as hard as I wanted the game
you know I study businesses and I study
people as much as I studied people
trying to figure out place you know so
it's kind of something I told the kids
yesterday you know when you see
transition really start to happen when
you really want to transition to
something master there's no limits you
know that don't let the word I ever put
limits on you you can do anything you
want to do but make sure if you have a
vision make sure the vision is written
you know make sure you have something to
actually chase and not just hoping and
wishing and all these different things
so if I thought I tell guys this all the
time
put your plans together and D work the
plan don't don't don't work somebody
else's plan right it's one thing about
the league I love the league but the
league is someone else's brand right you
have to create your own brand yourself
and your brain is whatever you feel like
doing whatever your heart is passionate
about chase it